Buongiorno buonasera Dipende da quando
state vedendo questo video benvenuti in
questa prima puntata di Guess the Song
anni 2000 oggi il concorrente non sono
io ma il buon Lorenzo nonché Anche
proprietario del canale non so se ve lo
ricordate Ricordate
il cameraman di turno faccio un po' di
cose No infatti vado a farti indovinare
Vai vai che facciamo questo quiz vado a
farti indovinare Non barare No volevamo
fare questo video perché io ho una
capacità un po' strana che adesso che
stiamo registrando non mi verrà fuori
neanche una volta di indovinare le
canzoni in un secondo Teoricamente
potrei fare bella figura Ma potrebbe
anche essere un video dove faccio delle
figure di merda Allora questo è il
nostro siccome questo video non ha
budget ehm Questo è il nostro tasto
rosso Quindi ogni volta che sono
Indovinate tu stoppi come faccio come
vedi fare così stoppi andiamo raccontaci
una canzone vai
[Musica]
Anche perché non era
ogni volta dobbiamo cambiare i bicchieri
[Risate]
Bravo grazie
[Musica]
eh Perché giustamente per il copyright
non possiamo far sentire la canzone con
l'audio originalissimo quindi
questa non la soglia
di Kelly Clarkson mai sentita
[Musica]
bravissimo
Poker Face di Lady Gaga bravissima
Madonna raga' Mamma mia ma' un treno
come A proposito di treni e i soulsister
è di 330
Non ci voglio credere Non ci voglio
credere Non ci voglio credere
però devo cambiare il bicchiere sai cosa
ci sta in tre bicchieri cosa tre
biscotti tre biscotti
ho capito che il video è Low budget ma
non a questi livelli
YouTube YouTube Gesù YouTube Gesù non è
così il titolo No dai qual era ignition
remix di R Kelly Eh ma sai che era la
mia seconda risposta
[Musica]
Ma che cazzo dici Dai non mi fare
censurare a un quarto di video Coldplay
bravo
Non so guarda andiamo avanti con questo
video ragazzi Perdonami Ah ma stai
utilizzando i bicchieri di plastica
Torri utilizzando questo
Plastic free contro questo video Basta
ragazzi censuriamo Questo video Lorenzo
Pro alla plastica Ecco diamo un buon
esempio compostabile andiamo avanti
[Musica]
Sì ma non si capisce un cazzo
e Murder on the Dance Floor Sofi Ellis
Backstreet Boys
[Musica]
Baby ba ba ba ba
Backstreet Boys No
non è backcity Boys
ma una conversione wish di loro
yannsyncà arrivando
questo qua non lo sapevi per il Trend no
Vabbè fai schifo questa canzone È
diventata famosa anche per un trend Ma
[ __ ] per un trend minchia nel 2006
mi ha ascoltato questi cavi tiktoker tik
toker Ma che tik toker
Thousand Miles
[Musica]
lui è lì in live in live l'hai visto No
non voglio vedere mettiamo la clip qui
adesso
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
non l'ho vista realmente solo ho fatto
finta
parte in USA Miley Cyrus
Metal e no scusatemi scusatemi questa
musica
irritante Mamma mia come sono messo ma
mi vergogno di me stesso
vai mica Bravo Gold No Porca [ __ ] eh
Silver Ma che cazzo Ma come cazzo
non lo so
come fai a sapere
non sembrava quella sembrava quella
[Musica]
è Rozzi di Paky
Eh non lo so però cosa devo fare Non lo
so
[Musica]
mi fido di te Jovanotti Lorenzo Lorenzo
non la potevo sbagliare questo Scusami
manca una della Swan la indovino con una
devi fare Tatà vai quando giocavi invece
di andare a scuola ragazzi Spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto bellissimo
mi è piaciuto un sacco
Siamo una squadra fortissimi di Checco
Zalone Comunque è stato un gran video
Bellissimo speriamo che il copyright non
ci ammazzi la prossima volta magari
facciamolo a mo' di sfida quindi
invitiamo qualcuno e facciamo un
Sarabanda un po' web Grazie a Giampiero
grazie a Giovanni Grazie a tutti quanti
per la regia di questo video lasciate un
mi piace un commento qua sotto e noi ci
vediamo come sempre ad un prossimo video
bella ragazzi
il cinema sempre il cinema